youtube my name is Antonio Guterres I'm
the United Nations I Commission for
Refugees and asking for your question I
think that the most important is for
each one of us to do what we have to
turn and to it based on others to do it
based on the best of all contestants and
then if there are issues that need
collective action I would select in the
present moment climate change and we
need to find an answer to this dollars
they need to make people understand that
societies are becoming all multi-ethnic
multi-religious multicultural and we
need to respect each other to know each
other and to be able to make the most
out of it and finally to understand that
the 21st century will be sent with
people on the moon more and more people
will be moving from one country to the
other son of a choice amount of
necessity where and we need to be able
to provide them the same set of Rights
EP from our citizens